apporte moi juste des céréales ces céréales sont
pleines d'ingrédients malsains je les ai
jeté ne jette pas mes affaires Frank
ces céréales sont pour les enfants profite de ce
pamplemousse tes quatre enfants stupides
aujourd'hui nous allons commencer un jardin
merde cette merde
Frank toi  besoin d'un projet de
stimulation mentale et d'un
horaire strict améliorera considérablement votre fonctionnement cognitif en
plus c'est un bon exercice
Frank nous allons devoir travailler
ensemble vous êtes un robot Butler Je ne suis pas
un majordome Frank Je suis un aide-soignant un
programme  pour surveiller et améliorer votre
santé physique et mentale ouais sortez
de chez moi si vous ne coopérez pas
avec moi autant ne pas être
ici si c'est comme ça que vous vous sentez je
contacterai le chasseur bon qu'est-ce que tu fais
tu as  un téléphone là-haut dans ce cerveau
tu l'appelles regarde tu as entendu ce
qu'il a dit il essayait de me mettre dans un
asile de fous je ne me souviens pas que le chasseur ait dit
qu'il n'y avait rien de mal avec ma
mémoire je vais bien je te le dis  Je vais bien
un deux  ree quatre cinq six sept huit
neuf dix ma mémoire va bien qu'est-ce que
je fais je parle à un appareil
je vous suggère de travailler avec moi je ne
jardine
pas tu ne peux pas faire ça super vite certaines choses
prennent du temps Frank